what's that believe nation welcome to
another YouTube hangout I'm excited to
be here with my friend one of my
favorite CEOs in the world mr. Stephen
Kelly he runs sage the accounting
software that I use to power my business
today we were talking about a really
important topic how to build and take
control of your personal brand Stephen
Kelly welcome aboard sir great to see ya
Evan you are my favorite rock star
personal brand social media Jedi Master
I love you I might have to add that to
my my Twitter bio now Jedi Master
according to Stephen Kelly I love it
well listen this is this is an important
topic we got a bunch of people already
joining in asking questions but we have
our own tradition and our own branding
here with Stephen Kelly who's got to
lead us off with some masterful quotes
so what do you got for us this time some
great quotes to kick off the broadcast
so the first one a brilliant brilliant
genius another genius Oscar Wilde said
be yourself everyone else is taken
second one from a amazing entrepreneur
Jeff Bezos of Amazon Brandon is what
people say about you when you're not in
the room mm-hmm and the last one great
American author Mark Twain if you tell
the truth you don't have to remember
anything and then a couple of Kelly
quotes just to finish it off I love it
so your attitude and brand will
determine how far your actions are drive
and how fast you run and then the last
one authenticity + optimism creates and
cultivates serendipity I love it these
are definitely Instagram abour oh yeah
good but you are not you are the master
I'd say Evan in terms of personal brand
you know you've you build a following
you're obviously massive out on newer
channels I guess the instagrams Facebook
but Twitter what quarter of a million
followers and the great thing about you
you never talk about you know your
following or any of those things but you
have built a movement and a lot of that
is about you Evan Carmichael
as the champion of
grafters and the heroes of the economy I
love well this is this is sure about
both of us and I think it's actually
great combination cuz because you're
there from this giant brand
internationally recognized I'm I've got
my own personal brand and so I'm excited
to see the variety of questions and get
and get some feedback helps so much
immerse myself before diving in do you
have any quick opening thoughts around
building a brand what entrepreneur
should do troubles that they go through
and building their brand up from your
experience I think ebonite you know with
all these things some of the best
entrepreneurs I met probably have very
diligo surprisingly and therefore you
ask the question why is it important to
build a personal brand and I think if
you build a really successful business
you as the entrepreneur you become part
of the business you are you know
inseparable from that and data to spore
that is actually you know in terms of
this is consumer data over 70% of
consumers are more likely to make a
purchase based on social media reference
particularly around personal brand and
it's very much you know in terms of the
personal brand of the entrepreneur the
leader I said a couple of things bits of
advice I guess is you've obviously got a
dream you've got a passion that is you
and and you want to put your personal
brand indelibly around your idea and
your passion so you you are part of part
of the brand promise and the other thing
is on these sort of things particularly
when you're getting off and starting out
you're getting from the get-go
I'd suggest you just pick two or three
areas where you want it either issues
based kind of personal brand items just
maybe even one or two just to say that's
something I care about and that's
something where I want to build my
personal brand so you get known and you
create a movement particularly on social
media where you get many followers and
something that you came in when you when
you kind of took over Sage you came in
and made it about youth made it about
veterans made about women like having
clear targets of who you wanted to help
of course entrepreneurs but within that
and then can you talk about how you came
up with like why those three and how
that intermediate your culture
yeah yeah I guess you know our mission
you know this Evan we got over three
million businesses around the world
using our technology to run you know
their payroll their accounting that Bank
and all these sort of great things to
allow them but out of bottom line our
mission is because we serve the heroes
of the economy it's kind of like you our
response is they deserve awesome
technology and that's where sage comes
in and then I think the other thing
about your person where we've taken kind
of one step further is we passionately
care about compassionate capitalism so
we think companies like us particularly
bigger companies should be giving back
to their community should be you know so
we do five days volunteering for our
colleagues to go out and help you know
bond people homeless people but we
actually corporately put our kind of
shoulder behind three kind of big causes
one is sort of veterans across Canada
across the u.s. across European
countries who have gone off to serve
their country and keep us safe and
typically you find out when they come
back there's massive problems with our
they're out cold drugs addictions can't
get a job all these sort of things and I
think there's a job we can do as a
business where we're helping them
transition back into civilian life
that's kind of one course that we
support through the foundation the
second course as you rightly said is
around women and particularly women
helping them in terms of confidence
self-esteem skills technology stem all
those areas because we believe in a
world of diversity equality and yes
absolutely we need to smash down all the
you know subconscious bias and all those
sort of things so we're really active
around that agenda and the third one is
around youth and you know trying to do
things like eradicate with charities
youth homelessness and stuff like that
because I think you all down downtown
Toronto you look at the the sidewalks
and it's not a good picture and I feel
the same way when I go to any big city
San Francisco all these cities there's
got to be a better way where great
talent amazing human capital is not left
to kind of roll on the sidewalk and I
think companies need again step in work
with charities and do the right thing
and really give people who may be a lost
their way an opportunity to believe so a
hashtag believed ever
I love it I'm still I'm still thinking
back about our last session together we
were talking about creating mythology
that that really stuck with me so you
create mythology now we're on the new
courses of action I love it
cool well let's get some questions guys
in the chat if you want to tag me it's a
lot easier for me to see the questions
coming in this is really the highlight
for both me and Steven we want to be
here chatting with each other is great
we want to be able to provide value to
you so put your questions down let's
start off with Mitchell
good morning evidence Steven what are
some of the first things you would do to
build your brain when starting out
that's a great question Mitchell I think
um and so the first thing is kind of
obviously your idea your passion and
then I think wants you to find that and
that should be pretty easy because
that's what you're gonna wear your
business around and then think about
what are the issues that you're really
going to care about connected with that
product that service that big idea and
there's a set of kind of pictures maybe
just pick one just pick one issue and
say that's something I'm really gonna
care about I'm gonna be quite active on
social I'm gonna you know post stuff on
YouTube and I'm gonna build a following
i'ma build a community around that or it
may be an issue where there is already a
community and how can you contribute and
that value to make sure that that is
amplified and really accelerated and
then obviously at the heart of that is
your business idea so I think the
important thing in terms your personal
brand it's all got to be congruent
it's got to be holistic and it's got to
be connected with what you're trying to
achieve in terms of your passion and
your big idea and when you do that I
think you've again it comes back to
whatever now I've talked about so many
times the power of authenticity is
overwhelmingly compelling so I just a
big idea you know your business you know
what you love you know what your dream
is and then find an issue around that
where you want a really champion that
cause so evident actually I ask you the
same question on behalf of Mitchell
because I think you've done a brilliant
and if I if anybody stopped me on the
sidewalk and said Evan Carmichael give
me one word I'd say I'd say that you I
can't I can't describe him in one word
but I'm gonna give you a few he does
create this whole
he champions entrepreneurs he is
passionate about grafters and heroes in
business heroes and he is allowing you
guys out there to believe what was
previously deemed impossible that you
can achieve and that's true kind of the
whole kind of believe campaign and the
mission Evan how would you describe it
you've got amazing personal brand and
your personal brand is so intrinsically
and holistically and authentically
aligned with what you do yeah I mean I
love everything that you said Stephen
all I would add is is thinking about
what a core value is for you and build
around that so for me believe is what
attracts a lot of people even you know
half of the audience that I have are not
even necessarily entrepreneurs yet like
they want to be entrepreneurs we're
thinking about entrepreneurship and so
we get them at a very early stage which
is amazing which I never anticipated or
expected but they love the believe
message and so if you have awareness
over what your most important core value
is that helps you create the brand and
also attracts the people who believe the
same thing is you so you know Steven
talks about velocity a lot he loves
velocity he wants to move fast he wants
to get things done you know if you
really love slow as molasses kind of
working don't try to hang around Steven
it's just not gonna work
right and then people who want to move
quickly you want to have big ideas and
want to make change real you'll
naturally be attracted to Steven to what
he's doing because velocity brings you
guys together and so figuring out what
your most important core value is I
think is super important and then
building your brand around that can
really help right next a chickadee talk
is saying hello evenin hello even hello
Evan and Steven greetings from the UK
all right local entrepreneur for you how
do you create a brand as a speaker what
advice would you give someone that is
just starting off in the speaking world
that's great so I guess and also I think
in terms of personal brand chickity pop
great where to start
so yeah halfway there but if you want to
go and on the circus speaking I think
again ideally you probably
something in terms of your core values
or what you've achieved or your
experience there's gonna be interesting
golden rule of everything is find out
what the audience need is what is the
requirement for you could be speaking
about additive growth capital you could
being about how to grow your business
you could be speaking about something
that you really care about but you've
actually got some experience of so you
know actually if you're a third stage
entrepreneur and you've started two
businesses done exit sold them on or
even had a couple of failures those are
the stories that people love and then I
kind of think the second thing is start
developing your story people call it the
narrative or whatever and and you've got
to become a rock on tour you've got to
become a storyteller and the most
compelling stories get told by just
great storytellers down the generations
and today you know for having
entrepreneurs who can share their
experiences and tell their story of you
know the good the bad the ugly what went
well what didn't go well how'd I win how
to overcome adversity how to smash holes
down all these sort of things makes a
compelling story to tell so kind of
wants you to find you know what's your
experience so what's the value add woody
wood and why would an audience want to
listen to you then what's the story then
I'll go and practice it with a few
people and then I kind of I'd also start
to think about how do I get into the
forum's where ultimately I get paid for
speaking potentially do you want to
build a business around going on the
speaker circuit and you can very quickly
sort of build up momentum and and the
more you do these sort of things then
the more you're gonna get asked back the
other thing I'd do is a go and watch
other other folks because I think
particularly the world of you know
checking out YouTube and stuff there's
so much amazing material out there and
nothing stops a bit of plagiarism
sometimes and no one's always got the
best ideas so if if you find ways the
key thing is how do you again build
social brand for yourself I'd to
actually get into the whole kind of
speaker circuit there's got to be a
catalyst and and to do that you're
probably going to have to build a brand
around social media where people
actually start coming to you as a
thought
and then through that you will
invariably be invited to speak at events
around your issues and from that it is
like a continuous fly rule it's a
success breeds success because you go
and speak you know dinner or a
conference or you speak online and then
people love it people like it people
recommend you and actually the speaker
circuit in the long term to build a
sustainable business is a referral
business so because you know evan will
go to a talk or he'll speak at a
conference thousands of people will say
Evan Carmichael is a Jedi Master we've
got a book in for next year and
literally is like that though and and it
goes viral seriously so start with the
big idea secondly check out the audience
thirdly become the storyteller you know
that really captivates the audience
build your brand personal brand through
social media with some provocative
compelling thought-provoking materials
and then I think you'll you'll get the
flywheel of success where you get people
within your network or want to kind of
book you out yeah tons of great
practical tips they're like pause and
rewind that and watch it back after two
to execute Stephen unloaded a lot of
wisdom there what I would add is if you
want to be a speaker then you need to be
speaking every day I want to see a
youtube video every day from you I want
to see Instagram stories every single
day from you you're gonna you're gonna
be terrible to the beginning that's okay
you're terrible at everything at the
beginning just start and keep going and
how do you find what to talk about I
think it ties in to our last question
where if you if you take Steven for
example he loves talking he loves
velocity loves the idea of making things
happen quickly and he's passionate about
entrepreneurs and then specifically
through women youth and veterans well
then that's what he should talk about so
like if you figure out what your most
important core value is and then the
audience that you care most about that
has to be a solid reason for you then
create content every single day talking
about those things and the better you
the better you do the better you get
people will notice I get all my speaking
gigs through my youtube channel I don't
I don't I don't write to anybody and say
hey
I speak at your event they come to me
because they see me talking about the
things I care about on my channel so I
think you have an output more you got to
create more content and it's never been
easier to stand out if you have a
powerful message actually ever not a
couple of that I think the world's
changed in the last 20 years and youyou
kind of typifies it but when you sort of
reflect what what's changed the world
now is a pull model where people pour
you the old world 20 years ago was a
push model you you know you have to be a
kind of street hustler and we're all
hustlers but what you do now to create
awesome content you told about Instagram
videos stories and then that creates
amazing compelling content where people
pull you in and say you know as you said
you you've never actually pitched
yourself as a speaker but you probably
get tens of requests a week so I think
it's very powerful to have that concept
you always create an incredible content
for a pull model and that's the world
the world that we live in today
some people join me in late there's
asking if the replay will be up after
yes give YouTube about 30 to 45 minutes
to process a video but then you can
watch it on replay for ever and ever
amen
Reggie actually this so this is a great
question thanks even that ties in to the
last one Reggie is talking about we
don't care enough about veterans in this
country how can we make people care and
you guys you were talking about before
and what I think is really great to
bring up is because as a speaker what do
you talk about if Steven was to be a
speaker this might be one of the topics
that he talks about
he's passion about veterans so so what
is your opinion Steven how do we get
people to care more about veterans yeah
I think other that's a great question
Evan uh if the question came from I'll
be honest from the US I'll be surprised
because the passion around veterans in
the u.s. is immense if the question came
from Canada are obviously we're in
Toronto for the Invictus games which is
all to serve veterans from the forces
who have come back with disabilities are
the mental illness or physical
disabilities and yeah I think with these
things because the good news is now
we're not having you know tons of Wars
all over the world which is fantastic
but again in 15 20 years ago when there
was Iraq and Afghanistan all these
conflicts around the world you know
you'd see it on the the main
or cast the whole time so it was very
fun of mine you see on social media
obviously still see stuff around whether
it's in Africa or Syria but when people
are coming back it kind of makes it top
of mind and with yes like social media
on news broadcasting you know what was
today's news you're like this actually
what's today's news is tomorrow's chip
paper cut your burgers off of the paper
of today's news and that's the reality
but we're veterans have almost forgotten
about you know I think how to bring it
to life and I speak quite a lot of our
veterans and we've become partners of
something I've mentioned called the
Invictus games which is an amazing game
jobs in Toronto Evon saw it and it set
the town alight before that I landed
this year it's going to Sydney it was
started by Prince Harry and just an
inspirational forum to number one give
amazing people have served their country
a platform to use for for rehabilitation
but number two it's done a really great
job of talking about the issues veterans
have coming back to their home countries
if you think about it if you've been on
a tour of duty of a year in a desert and
it's like 140 degrees and this it's very
inhospitable and you see a lot of
terrible terrible things then how do you
read us to kind of walk down Main Street
or go and get a job in a Toronto you
know garage or start a business or
whatever and readjust to the whole kind
of civilian life and you probably
haven't been trained in how to write a
resume do a pitch do a product launch
are create a website all these sort of
things where you know if you're an
entrepreneur you've got basic skills
that are missing so down to this reg I
think your question was how do we bring
the hawlucha and spotlight on veterans
the best way to do it is just go and
talk to some of these guys and when you
hear you hear their personal testimony
of you know some of these guys are met
for example a guy who was in a coma for
eight months and just think about what
that would be in a coma after getting
blown up by a roadside bomb for eight
months and then having to deal with that
getting flown back into you know a
situation where they're being
for day and night they're still
unconscious but then think about the
implication for their families right
their mom their pop the
boyfriend/girlfriend they all have to
come and visit them brothers sisters for
a month stay in there and they don't
know is it life is it death you know so
when you hear their personal stories and
hear the sacrifice they've made and
Reggie they did that for us guys Evan
for you for me to keep us safe to
believe in a free world to believe in
democracy all these sort of things we
hold close to our hearts and they have
made a sacrifice where actually they put
their lines lives on the line and and
you know sadly they've been blown to
bits or whatever that the tragic
situation is and then I think if you
listen to their stories and now check
this out actually go and go on YouTube
listen some of these heroes stories but
also how they overcome extreme adversity
of that situation or they've lost lost
limbs they have mental health issues
Pierce trdi and all these sort of things
and then they're going start a business
I know loads of veterans who have
started businesses built very successful
businesses and there are sparkling
examples of entrepreneurs who just
believe beyond human human potential
really it just is so humbling and so
inspiring you know I just don't know
anybody who wouldn't have tears and
their hearts and their heads totally
connect with these amazing heroes I love
it and and that's exactly how you do it
like if Steven wanted to leave sage and
he went to be a CEO anymore and decided
to start over and be a speaker talking
about veterans that's what he should do
like make one of those videos every
single day and post it online and then
he will get asked to speak at all these
different events eventually being paid
to do it right so that's how you do it
just pick the cause like he cares about
Veteran Affairs awesome you pick the
thing that you care massively about and
then speak from your heart and put it
out there and people will resonate yeah
you Reggie if you want to do it if you
if that's your thing you really care
about theirs obviously across the US
across Canada tons of veterans you could
probably either visit face to face on
on FaceTime or whatever and you could
actually with their permission interview
and tell their stories and post it and
then just the other amazing thing is you
know post it as they go through their
journey maybe they're starting a
business they're looking to grow they're
looking to take on their first employee
you could tell their story on their
behalf and that would be compelling and
captivating for the audience I'm sure I
love it alright let's move it on next is
Amanda saying Stephen and Evan how small
does that niche have to be do you
believe that after you start and take
the first step you find even more
clarity about your core values and your
niche I think Amanda I think the niche
ultimately I kind of think the most
important thing is the niche has got to
build a sustainable business for you and
with all these things if you believe in
there I think and and you go where the
audience is you create something of
value to your audience either a product
or service then you actually build your
own profile and your brand and then to
Evans point you develop in parallel
without what your core values are you've
got it you've just you're gonna nail it
just gonna smash the ball outlet part
now what happens I would always say I've
used Martin Luther King before how do
you climb a giant staircase if you take
the first step so Evan and I would
always advocate once you got your big
idea you know if you think your niche is
a market I'd say well let's let's create
a business and go after it let's create
that product and go for it and get our
brand out there and develop it because
what you tend to find is you know the
journey is never absolute and the
journey is never fixed it's evolving
it's like you know you you launch a
business you learn something you talk to
customers you probably didn't even know
that would be your customers and then
they give you great feedback on your
product and then you evolve your product
you improve your product and you improve
your personal brand you go and talk to
more customers you go and do a speaker
event and then you find out there's
other big issues out there and then you
can broaden your niche to be on more
encapsulating and and and much greater
value in the long term but the most
important thing I would add start you
know if you've got a big idea
you you think your personal brand is
gonna be part of it just crack on and go
for it and then don't be constrained
about what size the niches if it's
sustainable business you could grow
great business I love it I'm a big
believer that your purpose comes from
your pain as much as I think
entrepreneurs will solve all the world's
biggest problems and it's on us to you
know make our mark why I do what I do is
because of how painful it was starting
up and how low I felt on myself and
having no self-esteem just feeling like
garbage
like I was trying so much and nothing
was working out and so I just want to
make my path a little bit easier for
other people so the if you've been
through some pain and you made your way
through it then it's just natural that
you want to help other people who are
suffering from that same thing that you
suffered from and so if you're trying to
figure what your niche is that's a great
place to start
think about what was painful or
traumatic growing up or recently and how
you got through it and out of that
struggle you were reborn into the Jedi
Master that you are now right and so now
sharing that and helping other people
make that road a little bit easier is a
great place to start I think from
finding your niche yeah and today's
niche Evan is tomorrow's groundswell in
actually there's a great entrepreneur
who's a customer of ours a guy called
Liam from Kenny milk and he just ping me
a little quote with regards to this sort
of broadcast he said you know when we
started our business everybody told us
is a really kind of tiny niche now and
we care about it and they they have a
business which does awesome kind of milk
products but they're all organic and
they're really they really care about
the sauce and just sustainability and he
said you know our product is a labor of
love and it's rooted in where we've come
from and who we are which helps drive
the whole narrative for the business
people then become more and more
comfortable by seeing the face of the
people they're buying from and part of
part of our business is myself because
I'm part of the bank because I believe
in the course
today's niche is tomorrow's groundswell
you gotta get you gotta get team sage on
putting that up on Instagram they're
doing it they're on it now it's go girl
Joe come on get to work
they're on it they're all over the
quarter balls the quota balls okay
Agustin is asking how do you get people
who are scared of vlogging to start
vlogging so doing a video blog their
daily life I think if people are scared
of doing it to do it I think oh man
that's a great question Evan now I'm
gonna come back to you and ask you kind
of when was the first time you kind of
stepped off a cliff and then found you
could fly because you've got to start
just start doing it and even if you
shared it with the friends because
you're really really introvert and tried
the more you do it the more you practice
the better you become you know every
great sports person that said you know I
never got good by not practicing
I just got better and better and the
more I practice the luckier I am and
with all these things you know and what
I would say is just go to youtube find
out whether it's on Instagram whatever
channel whether it should be landscape
portrait how long it should be 30
seconds 20 seconds and then just try it
and then post it and then also create a
community where you can get feedback so
and listen to the feedback and then
evolve it and you'll get better and
better and better and one day you'll get
an Oscar for vlogging wow look at that
new category you'd be the first see I
like I like how Steven thinks you got
that velocity mindset oh hey that's
great you know you know you know this
this is that you are the master of yeah
and it's all video now so how did you I
guess think about it started and what
advice would you have yeah I was super
shy to be on camera I was really nervous
I had to have my sister or someone on my
team come in and focus the camera then
leave because I couldn't I couldn't have
anybody in the room even somebody on my
team in the room let alone strangers
walking down the street when you're
vlogging I think one of the best things
you could do honestly is just if that's
your dream to share it with somebody
who's gonna support you and who will
will push you and say do it you'll be ok
we have somebody in the live chat today
named Tommy who who confessed earlier on
that he wanted to do freestyle and so he
pushed them to get on insta
Graham and do a freestyle rap and he'd
never then Instagram live before he'd
never gone on and done his freestyle is
like okay let's we're gonna we're gonna
tune in and we watched hiding and
watched and Lily on my team watched and
a bunch of believe nation watched him
and and it was you know is this first
time do you know what he's doing and and
he crushed it and like here he is Tommy
doing his freestyle and he's giving me
lots of credit in the chat for helping
it was like I barely did anything like
you you did the work we just gave you a
tiny little bit of a nudge and so if you
can if you have anybody in your life
who's like that who if you tell them
your dream they'll just give you a
little bit of a nudge you say like make
that first video go just to build the
momentum get the velocity going because
once once a train leaves the station
it's a lot easier to keep chugging along
it's just getting out of the station
that first time that makes it really
difficult and don't give up keep going
keep posted I love it Tommy cheese is
not freaking out that we told this story
in the chat Tommy loves it freestyle
rapper let's see more of it Tommy T's
okay
rougarou JA I pronounce that okay just
for Stephen Stephen what kept you going
after all the downfalls I think it's
probably something keeps suger and is an
inherent belief a new core values and
you know III would say I've had many
kind of knocks as an entrepreneur and
probably we all have and things that I
started haven't gone to plan and I think
actually one thing Evan said it's so
powerful you know F stands for feedback
it doesn't stand for failure there's no
such thing as failure
it's just learnings and and the critical
thing is for me probably the thing on if
I reflect what could I learn Raja then I
would learn how to stop stuff there's
not working quicker and move on to what
could work you know I think especially
when we're so passionate about our idea
or our business or our passion there's
always a temptation to go on too long
and not take the feedback to learn what
work and it might be a little tweak and
then you kind of just taken off so I had
overcome adversity I think a very
practical suggestion is turn to people
who you love and who love you and get
kind of emotional support because that
will build your resilience and then also
you know with these things you know what
it's like you know you get a kind of
smash into a brick wall and you crumpled
down it sometimes takes a bit of time to
lift yourself after dust yourself off
and get back up there but time is a
great healer and things that seem really
bad on a Friday always seem a lot better
on the Monday it's another good one man
get the team get the team writing these
things down this is great come on Daryl
let's see that he's on it that was on it
you smile it away okay G Bevan is asking
can you can you both please talk about a
personal branding and creating a YouTube
channel yeah how you do that I think you
say G Bevan I think obviously you've got
your idea you know what you're
passionate about you probably in terms
of YouTube especially as a media and
channel you you will find your audience
there and you could probably go to
connect to communities who care about
the same things you do I'm reach out to
them and they'll probably reciprocate
and then I think that the next thing is
you want to become a thought leader so
you want to say kind of what are the
next stage what are the big ideas that
really gonna hold move this whole agenda
forward and that's where you can shine
and I think as with all these things
it's just taking that first step so you
know we could sit here and talk about a
YouTube channel or we could just get out
and start do some film and and poster
and then just kind of the whole concept
of the agility the iteration the
feedback you get from the community out
there the audience that you want to
serve everybody I think the good news
that you know there's lots of um I guess
downsides in terms of there's a few
downsides but there's so many outsides
around social media
and what you have is almost
instantaneous where there's a lot of
people actually back in you and back in
your success and giving you opinions on
kind of what works and what doesn't work
so that's a very powerful cocktail for
you to refine your idea improve your
YouTube posts and build a complete
personal brand what do you think you've
done is so well over I would say first
off expect to be terrible at the
beginning it's okay like what the video
you make you will be totally embarrassed
by that's awesome that's the starting
point I would say I would I would look
back on what Stephen just talked about
when we had the veterans question that's
we see what you want to do get in front
of a camera even now what we're used
like Stephens on a webcam off of a
laptop like that's all you need they're
not coming to you because you are of
graphic design expert genius right you
have thoughts on something get in front
of the camera speak about it whether
it's helping that's in in current events
it's happening or just something that
you see or their way that the world
needs to change and the movement you
want to create every day just get in
front of the camera and talk and and
that that little you know thought piece
or rant that Stephen went on was you
know two three four minutes long great
that's your video for the day and do
that every single day and post that to
your YouTube channel and as you start
getting attention as you start getting
speaking offers you start making
advertising revenue you start getting
brand deals then you can put that money
into making a better design in the
template and editor and all that kind of
stuff but I think people think they need
a lot more than than they do to start
like you have a studio right here in
your phone so start just get the things
that are inside your head and get it on
the tape and post it and do that every
day
yeah and God that Chey's versa and Evan
if you could see our expensive studio I
might take a picture myself here it's
there so we this is the expensive studio
that's it you see it's a laptop and
Stephen Kelly connected through amazing
high-speed broadband to the Jedi Master
on some cooler technology and a great
microphone
like this that's cool but seriously it's
just you know ten art is there to be
used for you guys as entrepreneurs to
get your message out to reach your
audience to start communities that
you're thinking build build build a
great sense around your personal brand
yeah and even me I'm working off of a of
a webcam and then I got the microphone
but for the longest time I use this
little blue Yeti microphone and that's
it we're starting we're getting a
conversation all these people are all
you guys are watching and you got
Stephen who's running this multi-billion
dollar company you've got me with 1.3
million subscribers on my channel and
we're still using technology and gear
that for the most part is open and
accessible to you too and so it's just
starting let's just starting it's just
doing it's just going I love it
another question for Stephen I write
doctor Sten is saying question who
inspires Stephen what books as he read
people he watches etc last hey doctors
saying great question number one top of
mind Evan Carmichael that's the serious
point I you know I met Evan about three
years ago in Chicago and we got to know
each other you know honestly dr. Stein
so many brilliant people either appear
on TV or YouTube or you know and they're
rock stars but there's so many people
you probably meet in your network who
just satisfy you every day of the sort
of books I think there's there's so many
fantastic books actually people like
Elon Musk amazing book smart Benioff I
should Sheryl Sandberg
all these people you know there are
inspirations and they cast a big shadow
but I think what I would say with with
the reading books there's always a few
things that you learn you know two or
three things and and I know Evans
consummate kind of the absorber of
information and we all all believe we're
in it you know and entrepreneurs
Teaching Hospital so we're learning all
the time we try new things but I think
the most important thing you know dr.
stem would be stay true to yourself
build your network learn from people get
connected through obviously channels and
social media and also go to
there's some famous folks but you're not
gonna learn how to run a business in a
book you're not gonna actually learn
probably going to Stanford Yale or
Harvard you're gonna go through the
university of entrepreneurship in real
life that's where you get your knocks
and the awareness all right Rose Martha
is saying evidence Steven how did you
feel knowing that others were watching
you and judging you people you know who
are critical it's somewhat embarrassing
making content before you have other
friends so honey get started making
content when people are judging you do
you know what Rose mofford I think do
you know what
and then really interesting thing ever
when was the first video you made you go
back and watch that Rose mofford
if I go back even to videos I made a
year ago or I went back to do a speech
for someone's graduation or idea their
speech at a big event sometimes I look
back at myself and I cringe I think I
can't believe that's me but you just got
to get out and do it because the reality
is you know Rose you you're out there
you've got an idea you've got something
to say you've got a point of view you've
got core values people want to listen to
you if you're interested and if you're
adding to the debate and you're creating
value and you're building a brand and
bringing people with you or you're
contributing to something kind of in a
bigger cause then people will think your
interest and they'll want to know more
and the the worst thing you can do is to
try the community of your participation
so you just gotta jump in there with
both feet and just start straight away
and and when I did it and on social
media I've made loads of mistakes you
know and even now whether I do it
landscape or portrait sometimes I forget
silly little things like that but
ultimately you know Rose I think that
the most important thing is be really
clear in 20 seconds what you want to say
just have one message and give them one
message keep it simple and there's
beauty and simplicity and then just the
next time you go on do you know little
and often lots of kind of Rolling
Thunder of your message out there and I
just think with
thinks you just gotta take the first
step you gotta be like that Evan
Carmichael who's top of the cliff and he
jumps off and he flies like an evil well
somebody let me know that I set up my
YouTube account November was it November
10th 2008 so we're coming up on ten
years is YouTube account so that's crazy
so this is a work in progress right this
isn't just come out fresh from day one
what I would say to that comment is what
I've tried to do is train myself that
any time I'm worried about somebody
else's judgment of me then I have to go
and do that thing the train the muscle
if I am worried about not doing
something or doing something because of
how anybody around me will judge me then
I have to do it just to do it just to
feel the judgment eat it grow from it
and move on so it's not only
business-related like I I painted my
nails not that long ago you can this
most of it's gone but because my dance
team was at a nail salon and they wanted
me to do it and I was worried about
being judged and so then I had to do it
and so just developing that muscle yeah
because as you go and do bigger things
if you become a CEO of a giant
corporation or if you become a big
youtuber then any any anything that you
start is going to be seen with so many
more eyes there'll be a lot more
judgement on you and so learning to love
the judgment like that's your chance for
growth so when I see whenever I'm
worried about being judged doesn't that
means I have to go off and do that thing
it's good hey Evan always remember this
quote feedback is the breakfast of
champions nice so like Rose Rossum offer
you get feedback I get feedback great
entrepreneurs take feedback all the time
and they learn more they absorb it
sometimes they think actually I'll
ignore that feedback because I don't
think it's appropriate or they'll say an
eight you're absolutely right and they
evolve and they change and they change
their message and maybe change their
product and service and that feedback if
it's from customers who have committed
and invested in you and your personal
brand then they absolutely are back in
you 100
I love it I feel like we need a Stephen
Kelly like eating the Cheerios in the
morning with what's the quote down the
side Darryl make it happen Darryl we
want Stephen Kelly and Cheerios feedback
is to breakfast it's the breakfast it
and we're gonna do that we're gonna film
that we're gonna post it per CEO is
saying okay this is an interesting one
evidence Stephen when I change my brand
and I need to bring it to my team how do
I make sure everybody's on board with
those standards and values I personally
I think it's a great question you know I
I would say a lot of its around
authenticity so I think the values have
got to be connected to your business
your idea what you're trying to achieve
and the values really speak to and when
I talk to people who are working great
companies our company other companies
they'll say actually the values are the
things that motivate them to go the
extra mile so I think it really is
important and you you kind of crack the
code if you can get your team to really
connect with the core values and how do
you do this if they're all in the same
office is easy to just go down the bar
and talk to them about core values
what's important to you what what what
you value around making customers
successful being obsessed about
customers exceeding their expectations
around you for whatever it is then you
will be very clearly able to connect
with them and tell whether they share
the same core values I think this is
kind of one of those lines in the sand
if you've got people who don't share
your values then they're probably better
off going to work for someone else
because its core values are really you
know that it's the flame that keeps
keeps everything alive and it keeps it
burning you've got to be the whole bit
of a flame and the hold of a flame has
the core values that light up the
company and even when you grow a
company's 20 30 40 50 hundred people is
how do you kind of bottle that that set
of core values and totally embed it in
the DNA of the work because it because
the values drive the behaviors and it's
you know if you Altima t why it's
important is if if you said everybody
we love our customers we go the extra
mile for our customers or we want it the
value could be we're innovators we're
disruptors we're going to invent the
future for our customers whatever you
choose is your core value that you hold
the candle to then that should be
embedded deeply in the culture of the
company you're building and that will
affect the behaviors and if there's
people who don't share your values then
honestly they publish shouldn't be
working for you there's a great question
and for me I almost started with belief
so I got to build it from my from the
ground up
so I've attracted people who love it and
I haven't had to change it but I think
it's interesting hearing Stephens
perspective because he joined an
existing company that's been around for
a long time and your your what three
four years in like yeah absolutely
right like 15,000 people 14,000 people
you got a hip so if somebody's if you're
coming in new and somebody doesn't align
how do you what's the process how do you
get people either on board or off to a
different opportunity Paper Co I'd say
right right in the get-go
if you meet people through social media
LinkedIn whatever I put it up there in
terms of your brand your website your
shop window particularly on social media
what your values are I'd be really
explicit about them and and you will
find that that will attract people you
will find that that will be you know
like you'll become a talent magnet for
people with shared values and you know
if you go through a process where you
interview them FaceTime or whatever or
face to face you can say look these are
our core values this is what we believe
in this is how we're going to change the
world you know if that doesn't float
your boat then you know you can go
somewhere else there's probably plenty
of jobs out in the US at the moment you
know it's full employment I think
there's point nine percent unemployment
in Portland Oregon at the moment so it's
what three people so reality is there's
a lot of jobs for people out there and
if they don't get inspired by your
vision your mission your business your
passion and your core values then
they're not the right people to really
double down and hunker down and build a
great business with you but I'd be
really transparent I'll tell them right
up front even
all they joined your company and your
adventure well Percy was still in the
live chat nice saying thank you so much
exclamation point so glad we were able
to help there we're at time alright he's
crazy how quickly it goes Steven how do
you want to wrap this up put a bow on it
final message for believe nation on
personal branding so I believe nation I
would say actually what everybody could
do on the broadcast today is go do two
things go and Google yourself and see
what appears right because it's
important that ultimately you have your
own personal brand consistently
appearing on digital and social channels
right out across the estate and then
think about what that is it's the
current state and then say to yourself
in a year's time I want my personal
brand when I Google myself to flag up
and the lights go on with one thing that
I want to be remembered for so back to
the point created mythology creating a
legacy what is it you want to be famous
for whether you are on the speaker
circuit whether you've got a product
whether you got a service you've got a
dream so when when you google yourself
in a year's time what's the one thing
that's gonna come up and light up you
know your phone or your laptop or
whatever device you're on and then think
about how do I get from here where I am
today with maybe either no personal
brand or a brand that's not consistent
where I wanna be and how do I get in a
year's time to really being true to
myself and living my personal brand and
that will amplify my business success
well bunch of people saying thank you
people are upset that it's already over
we'll do it again next month
got the commitment to serve you guys
Stephen thank you so much for your time
today thank you everybody for watching
tuning in we believe in you I want you
to continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love much love go thank you very much
great fun